And Five.
Okay.
Four,
three,
two.
One
has it hanging up on me.
Will live live.
Dr Phil.
Well live.
Someone's calling you.
What's going on
those people,
some of those people I
was trying to find said,
oh shit,
let them worry out of all the years
you've been doing your show and all the
years you've been given advice.
Hi,
how did this
catch me outside?
Girl,
how did this happen?
All the know all the different shows.
If you made a monster,
I know,
I mean it's my moment of infamy.
No,
seriously.
This girl comes home with her mother and
her mother actually brings her own of
course,
and if she's a train wreck and we work
with her and we send her to this ranch
for like four months,
right?
She goes for a long time and
makes a complete turnaround,
does a really a great job.
They say she's become a leader.
She's working with all these girls doing
a great job and then she graduates and
I remember this last shot and we do this,
this piece at the ranch.
She jumps up on this fence and is
smiling and everything and waving at all.
One night home with her mother one night
and her mother's finding people that
are trashing her,
the mother on,
on,
uh,
the social media platforms
or mother tracks him down,
backs into who they are,
gets their phone numbers,
calls him up,
yelling into the phone,
calling them names and stuff,
gets the daughter involved
one night crashes.
So they come back for a followup like,
I don't know,
month or two later.
And when they come I say,
okay,
we're going to have him back.
They walk out,
I have the audience completely empty.
I have nobody there to play too.
I mean,
250 chairs,
empty,
nobody in the house but me,
the mother and the daughter,
that's a good move.
And they go,
whoa,
where is everybody's?
Well,
you don't need anybody,
we're just here to talk and you know,
keep things rolling.
Right.
And they were dumbstruck,
they,
there was nobody there to
showboat for or play too.
And there was like a 15 minute interview.
They had nothing to say.
And off they go.
And then this phrase
that got turned into a,
you know,
whatever,
a meme or whatever they call it,
um,
it just went crazy.
And what she was nominated
for a grammy or Siri.
I'm serious.
Uh,
I take no credit or blame.
I,
you know,
I just,
what I could and haven't seen her since.
I wish everybody,
well,
maybe she'll turn,
so maybe it'll grow her up.
She'll turn some posse valve.
But I hope so.
Well,
that's
good attitude and very
healthy attitude for you.
But it is,
when something goes viral like that,
something's strange that for whatever
reason it catches and takes off.
It's,
it doesn't make any sense.
It's a very weird thing.
It makes no sense.
She's on a billboard on sunset,
a giant billboard.
Oh really?
Huge.
Enormous billboard.
It's like one of those side of the
building billboards where they,
you know,
they put the graphic up and
covers the entire building.
It makes no sense.
Seriously.
There's people curing cancer and
you can't find them with both hands.
Exactly.
Nobody has any idea who won the
last Nobel Prize for science,
but you know,
more power to her.
I if if she can turn
into something positive,
she have talent.
Have you ever heard any of her music now?
I have no idea.
I've either seen her on your show.
I appreciate you bringing that up.
Sorry.
But it's just so strange that one
train wreck could for whatever reason,
catch on and then all of
a sudden it's gigantic.
Yeah.
They say that somebody signed her
and paid her millions of dollars.
Seriously
close to a million dollars
from a makeup company.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh,
well,
okay.
There you go.
I mean,
if that's happening,
right,
like what would your advice be then?
Would your advice be,
Hey,
get your shit together
and stop being crazy?
Well,
she's making a lot of money off of being
crazy and her opportunities before that
were probably severely limited.
Well,
they had to be.
And what I hope now that this,
even though this certainly is a quirk,
what I hope now is that she's surrounded
by mature people with business heads on
their shoulders and development people
that will actually guide this in a way
that it's not 15 minutes.
Yeah.
You never know.
You know?
That's what I hope.
Well everybody thought the Kardashians
are going to be 15 minutes and it's been
15 years.
Yeah.
But there's been,
you know,
people make fun of them and there's
some good things there to make fun of.
They do things to be made fun of.
But there's also from very smart business
and branding that's gone into that as
well.
Oh,
100%.
And you know,
and I was actually very impressed with
her that she actually went to the White
House to talk about prison reform.
Right.
For people that are unjustly accused and
are being been in jail for too long for
things that they didn't do.
And that's something she's
actually passionate about.
Yeah.
And I know Kim and she's
actually a very nice girl,
very smart and all.
And you know,
they,
as I say,
they've done some very brilliant
branding and it's certainly paid off.
It's just so fascinating when
something catches like that girl,
what is her name?
The catch me outside,
uh,
Danielle goalie or something.
Yeah.
Cause I didn't know her as
the catch me outside girl.
But if she didn't say that one phrase.
Yeah.
And she just said that I think to her
grandmother or somebody in the audience,
I know it didn't even
register with us at the time.
Wow.
It was,
it wasn't a standout phrase
in the interview or anything.
It just pass by.
Somebody just grabbed it and,
and then it became a meme.
Yeah.
What a weird world we live in.
Yeah,
no kidding.
I mean it has to be a lot
of responsibility to try to
give people advice and try
to straighten her life
out and show them the,
the flaws and the errors
that they're making.
Yeah,
it is.
And you know,
people ask me sometimes they say,
you know,
doc field or problems,
you think problems are as simple
as you make them out to be.
And the truth is,
I don't think problems are simple at all.
In fact,
I think problems are really,
most of the time,
pretty complex.
They're pretty layered.
They have a lot of different origins
and they're oftentimes Comorbid.
A lot of things exist together.
So I don't think problems
are simple at all,
but to solutions are often simple.
Don't you think?
I mean it's Kinda like the old joke.
You go the doctor and you say this hurts.
And he says,
well then don't do that anymore.
It's a lot of times
it's very simple in it.
Somebody will have a complex thing that
comes from childhood or maybe it's a
drug background or they've
had trauma in their life.
But the solution is change your behavior.
I mean,
stop rewarding bad behavior.
Uh,
choose a different path in life.
Just behave your way to success.
Sometimes the solutions are very simple,
even though the problems are very complex
because at some point you have to stop
focus econ.
Why?
And start focusing on what
instead of why it happened,
what am I going to do to change it?
So sometimes the solutions
are pretty simple,
but implementing those
solutions are often very,
it's often very difficult for
people to change their lives,
change their patterns.
It is.
And,
and patterns is the key.
Um,
you know,
nobody does anything in pattern
if they don't get a pay off.
And if you can identify,
that's why.
That's why insights so important.
That's why I think it's the number one
outcome to whether somebody is going to
respond to a talking therapy.
For example,
if somebody can identify
what their payoff is,
where they really can figure out,
I'm doing this repeatedly and my
payoff is I don't have to work,
or I don't get held accountable for this,
or I'm escaping accountability over here,
or I get attention or sympathy,
or if they can figure
out what their payoff is
and they can then control that,
whether it's for themselves
or their kids or whatever.
If you control the currency,
then you can control the behavior.
Yeah,
it's,
it just seems that people
have a,
they have this comfort in their patterns
and even if their patents are self
destructive,
he had been his drug abuse
or alcoholism or did those,
those,
the comfort in those patterns
falling into those patterns.
It seems very compelling to a lot of
people and payoffs don't necessarily mean
that it's a positive payoff.
Right?
I mean,
it pay off for taking
heroin as you get high.
And so you're high for a while.
That's not a positive pay off,
but it's a payoff.
Right?
And if you,
if you get high and so you don't get a
job and you don't take care of your kids,
that's a payoff.
That you're not doing
things that you need to do,
that you should be accountable for.
It's a pathological payoff,
but it's a pay off.
None the less.
And so that does reward you,
even though it's a pathological payoff.
It's a pathological thing.
Uh,
you call it a reward and if you,
but if you can identify
that where they say,
look,
I'm,
uh,
I'm not doing what I need to do and I
need to stop rewarding myself in that way
and hold myself,
kind of need to be there for my kid.
I tell my kid I'm going to be there
every day and I don't show up because I'm
high on drugs,
then you know,
I need to stop doing.
I don't need to not let myself get away
with that and instead require myself to
show up for the kid.
When I say I do say I will,
and then you see what's in the kid's eyes.
You share the experience with them.
Now that becomes your payoff,
so then you'll start
showing it for your kids.
Yeah.
How,
how many people take your advice?
How many people just listened and
try for a little bit and then bail?
You know,
it's hard to say because I think our,
sometimes our most productive guest are
the ones that don't get it because the
mail we get,
they'll say,
oh wow,
that guy didn't get her to,
that woman didn't get it,
but I saw myself in them and
I'll never say that again.
I saw them being such a right fighter
or I saw them being so hard headed or so
oppositional and I s I heard them say
things I've said and they laughed and
didn't get it.
I got it on.
Never do that again.
So sometimes those that don't get it
at all while they're there are the ones
that are the best teaching tools for
the millions of people that are home
watching.
Yeah.
That's interesting,
isn't it?
When you watch people fail and you go,
oh,
okay,
I see that in myself.
Yeah,
I just got to not do with that guys do it.
And then also do you see the stubborn
pigheadedness that some people have what?
They won't listen to advice and you could
clearly see how they're ruining their
lives by not being honest.
And sometimes the story that we might
have is maybe extreme where you say,
I don't do all six things they're doing,
but I do two of them and they
are in sharp relief to me.
So I get that.
I ain't gonna do that anymore.
So I mean,
that's where I think you
get a pay off and you know,
people go and find these
things on the Internet.
I mean,
last year,
you know,
we have a channel where we put up,
different clips from a divorce shows
or parenting shows or whatever.
And we had over 2 billion views.
You know,
last year or people just going and finding
that information and looking at it.
So I know people are seeking
the information out and
looking at it beyond the
show itself.
So,
you know,
they must be seeking information and
we just don't have a good distribution
system,
uh,
for mental health in America.
So I think they look,
I think they're hungry for it.
And I looked for it.
Well there's so many people out there
that are trying to do better at trying to
get their lives in order and you know,
shows like yours and,
and you know,
just advice shows people that are
giving out inspiration and knowledge.
It's so,
it's such an important
thing for people to,
especially for people that didn't grow
up with wise parents or they'd be a good
support system around them.
No,
I think that's,
that's true.
And I grew up with an alcoholic father
and it was a pretty violent home and,
and he was a really bad alcoholic.
And I know having grown up in that,
you wind up with what I call a damaged
personal truth and you feel second class.
And the problem that kids make.
And uh,
cause I know I did it
and I see others do it,
is you compare your personal truth,
what you know about yourself and how you
really live and what's really going on.
You compare your personal
truth to everybody else's
social mask because you go
to school and you know,
well I know that last night the
windows got kicked out of my house.
I know that the utilities got turned off.
And I know there was a big fight in my
kitchen last night and the kid sitting
next to me,
he's got on a shirt that's all ironed
and his face is all bright and clean and
you know,
he looks like he's just got it all
together and you compare yourself to that
person,
that kid,
and you feel like you're second class.
And the problem with that is we
generate the results in life we think we
deserve.
So if you think your damn is,
do you think your second
class you will generate
results that you think a
second class person deserves.
So if you don't fix your personal truth,
then you'll spend the
rest of your life saying,
well,
you know,
those really good results,
those belong for somebody else.
It's not for me.
That's for somebody else.
And you'll settle for second best and
you won't get what you might otherwise
generate for yourself if you
don't fix your personal truth.
And so I think a lot of
people are struggling looking
for a way to kind of get
out of feeling not good about
themselves and damage self esteem,
damage,
self worth.
And they really don't know where to go.
So,
uh,
and that's why I do the show.
I don't look,
I'm not under the misapprehension that
we're doing eight minute cures up there.
I mean,
come on you,
we're not doing that.
But I think if you can point
people in the right direction,
if you can raise their awareness,
you can get them thinking about it.
You can create a narrative
where they at least say,
you know,
how do I feel about myself?
I mean,
is there stuff I need to resolve?
what am I saying to myself?
If you can get them thinking about that,
then you know,
maybe you've done something.
Yeah.
You know,
Tony Robbins once said once said,
it's incremental changes over the long
haul and the way you have to look at it
as if these two boats are going in a
parallel direction and one of them just
shifts five degrees
over the course of time,
this boat is going to be in a far
different place than the other boat that's
going in the same way.
It was always going.
Yeah.
And the important thing to realize as
well is the next year is going to go by
whether you're doing something
about your life or not.
I mean,
we're,
we're sitting here right now at the end
of February and the next 10 months are
going to go by whether somebody is
working to make change or whether they're
not.
And they may think,
you know,
Oh my God,
I'm so far away and I'll never get it
under control or I'm so behind in my bills
or I'm so,
uh,
you know,
just depressed or,
uh,
everything is so out of control.
Well,
you know what,
you make those incremental changes and
then you know pretty soon in December you
go,
Hey,
I'm way better off than I
was at the end of February,
so shit,
you made little changes and they
all ended up and if you don't,
by the end of the year,
you're just in deeper.
So every little bit matters.
Yeah.
I,
I tell people to write things down.
I said one of the best ways to get
things done is to write things down.
Write down what you're trying to get done.
Write down what you need to get done on
a longterm basis in which you need to
get done in a short term basis
and write off a checklist.
Force yourself.
Be Accountable.
Yeah.
The difference between a dream and a
goal is a timeline and accountability.
Accountability is gigantic.
You got to have somebody,
whether it's yourself or a friend
or somebody that's going to say,
look,
did you do what you said you
were going to do by this time?
And if you don't hold
your feet to the fire,
because I mean,
just sitting around dreaming some day,
some day I'm going to get a different job.
Some day I'm going to change.
This will someday ain't a day of the week.
You know,
there's Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday.
Look on your counter
some days not on there.
So you got to say,
okay,
I want to take this small step by here,
this small step by their,
this most step by there.
And then pretty soon,
you know,
we don't leaps tall
buildings in a single bound.
We take it a floor at a time.
And then
all the years you've been doing your show,
you've developed a real community,
right?
I mean,
you,
you really have made an impact.
If you stop and think about all the people
that your show is touched and all the
people that have listened to your advice
and all the people that have taken that
advice and,
and made those little incremental changes
in their lives and set those goals and
held themselves accountable,
that's a pretty significant thing.
Well,
I hope so.
I mean,
I,
I think,
I know that there's a stigma attached to
mental illness and that really bothers
me.
There should not be,
I mean,
having depression or anxiety or whatever.
To me,
it should have no more stigma than having
a knee injury or kidney infection or
diabetes.
But there is a stigma attached to it and
I've tried to talk about this in a way
where it's okay to talk about
it and not be ashamed of it.
It's,
it's okay if you've got anxiety,
you've got PTSD,
w whatever,
it's okay,
let's talk about it.
Let's get hell for it.
Get it behind you and move on.
I mean,
just not,
it's not something that
you should be ashamed of.
What do you mean
when you talking to someone
that maybe has depression,
do you try to get them to exercise first?
Do you try to get them to visit a
psychiatrist immediately and get on
medication?
Like do you take it on
a case by case basis?
Well,
I do,
but you have to approach it.
Everybody has a philosophy about it.
And I'm not saying that mine's
any better than anybody else's,
but I do have a philosophy about
it and I'm very slow to medication.
I mean,
I,
I think you used medication
for biochemical replacement.
I mean,
if for some reason your body is not
making enough of something it needs,
then maybe you support it
short term biochemically.
But
I look at depression.
There's a lot of ways you can break it up,
but I look at it like,
is it exogenous depression
or endogenous depression?
I mean,
is it coming from the inside
out or the outside in?
Is it because you're
reacting to something?
I see a lot of depressed people that
in a sense it makes sense,
right?
I mean,
you look at their life and you say,
well,
if you're not down about this,
you should be,
I mean,
you've lost your job.
You've gotten a divorce,
your health is in the shitter.
You're,
I mean,
you should be down about this.
It's external things.
So you don't need a pill.
I mean,
put somebody in a chemical straight
jacket because their life's fallen apart.
What the hell's that gonna do then?
That's just putting goggles on
him where they can't see it.
I would much rather get them to
behave their way to success and say,
what are you reacting to
that you're depressed about?
Let's put that on a to do list and start,
like you said,
write it down and start
crossing those things off.
Let's figure what's an action plan to
change this action plan to change the next
thing I clean.
And then when you start doing that,
then you generally see their mood lift.
A lot of people that are depressed or
just realistically reacting to a crummy
circumstance in their life.
It's not necessarily a a mental illness,
it's just a re realistic reaction
to a bad spot in their life.
Yeah,
that's such a way good way of putting
it to that you weren't in a bad state
looking at this might
be something wrong with,
yeah,
you're in denial.
Yeah.
I mean if,
if,
if you've gotten a divorce,
lost your job,
your health's in bad shape,
your kids are alienated
from you and you're saying,
I'm fine,
then you're not in touch with reality,
you should be bothered by that.
And,
and I think to give somebody a pill to
mask your feelings about that just keeps
you off task.
I don't,
your pain's a good motivator.
Um,
you know,
I grew up in like Texas and Oklahoma
and I don't know you've ever done this,
but we were,
I used to spend my summers in the
thriving metropolis of Monday,
Texas.
You ever heard of Monday,
Texas?
No.
It's him.
You in?
It's a U.
Dot.
It's got like 2000 people in it,
but in the summers it
would get hot in Monday,
Texas.
And when I say hot,
I mean you look out in the backyard
and your dog burst into flame.
This is what I'm talking about.
So we would be going to the
swimming pool or something,
barefooted.
And you get halfway across an asphalt
road and you look down and you're like,
Holy Shit,
me,
your feet are just on fire.
So what are you going to do?
I mean,
that is painful.
You're going to do one of two things.
You're either going to make a u turn and
get your ass back over to the side of
the road and getting the grass or you're
going to run to the other side and get
off the road and getting the grass.
But you are not going to stand there in
the middle of the road and melt yourself
down to the knees.
Pain is a motivator.
Paint is not necessarily always bad.
If you're in pain,
it's going to motivate you
to move to change something.
And the mash that with drugs to dull
that pain with drugs is not necessarily a
good thing.
That is wise,
wise advice and um,
I wish more people thought that way.
Particularly more doctors.
You know,
I have so many friends that have gone to
a doctor cause I'm not feeling so good
and that they're almost
immediately wanting to throw
him on something that's not
smart.
And all the years you've been doing this,
have you noticed like was
depression as prevalent like the,
the term depression or was it,
it doesn't,
I mean I don't really remember it
being a thing when I was a kid that was
discussed the way it's discussed now.
Now it's discussed the way people
discuss all sorts of other ailments.
Is it just an awareness thing?
Is it just people
were thinking about it
now in different terms?
Well,
I think as part of the narrative now,
and I think with social media,
with the Internet,
not just social media,
I think there's just a lot more,
it's a lot more in the nomenclature.
Um,
and there's a lot more awareness about it.
but I think it was just as prevalent in
the fifties and sixties as it was now.
But in the fifties and sixties there
wasn't a psychologist on every corner and
there is now and there wasn't
sub doctoral licensing then.
I mean,
you,
what does that mean?
Well,
back then that you had to have a phd or
an MD as a psychiatrist to see patients.
Now they have marriage.
And family therapist,
they've licensed social workers,
they have different levels,
uh,
where you can do independent practice.
So that's broadened the number of
people that can provide services.
And some people think that's a good thing.
Some people think it's not.
Um,
I generally think it's a,
it's a good thing because I think
[inaudible] 58% of our rural markets today
have no psychiatrist available
and something like 50 or
roughly have no mental
health professional available at all.
None.
So there's just nobody available to
help people in the outlying areas.
So I think the more people you
can get into the profession,
uh,
so long as there's a degree
of competency is better.
But,
you know,
I think it's always been prevalent.
I just think people didn't
talk about it very much.
It's just something that I swallowed
or they took the church or,
yeah.
Yeah.
When you see,
uh,
you know,
these,
all these folks that
are on medication today,
I mean,
how many of these people do you think
legitimately should be on medication?
I mean,
is it something that you can assess?
You know,
I,
I can't answer that in terms.
I mean I'm sure there's
research of people,
how many people are on medication.
But in my personal experience,
most of the people that
I see on medications,
in my opinion,
don't need most of the
medications they're on now.
That's just anecdotal.
It's my opinion.
He asked me to hand you a research
survey or study to support that.
I can't hand it to you or
I can't point you to one.
I'll just tell you after 45
years in this experience,
I see people that are on medication,
they've usually seen,
um,
someone for six or eight minutes and said,
you know,
I'm really feeling kind of down a blue.
Yup,
here's some Prozac,
here's this,
here's that.
They give it to them.
They don't even really ask why and they
just give it to him because medicine has
become a high volume business.
And that's not necessarily
the doctor's fault.
I mean the way that it's now
funded and Medicare and Medicaid,
you got to turn them
and burn them and yeah,
or you can't stay in business.
And so it's a high volume business.
And so they throw pills at them because
they don't have an hour to sit down or
don't take an hour to sit
down and talk about and say,
well,
was fine at what's going on.
Is there a reason?
Like I said,
if this guy's got five parts of his life
that have gone down or a woman has got
three or four areas of her life
that have really gone down in,
in quality,
then they should be having poor mood.
So why mask that?
Let's come up with an
action plan and change it.
So most of the people I see on medication,
not all,
but most of the people I see are on too
many medications in too high a dose or
either don't need it at all and I'm
really bothered by polypharmacy.
That's where I really get frustrated.
Yeah.
This is what you're saying is
a very common sense approach,
but it's not the norm today.
No.
It seems like more
people are treating this,
you know,
air quotes,
depression issue as if
it's a medical disorder,
like,
like diabetes or something
where you need medication.
Yeah.
And look for a lot of people that works.
I mean you give people a
mood elevator and they say,
hey,
I feel better.
And then maybe they change their life.
Maybe they move their life
into a more positive direction.
They can wean themselves off of it.
Because one of the things
about depression for example,
you're using that as an example,
is you get what's referred to
as psychomotor retardation.
There's a,
there's a lessening in activity level.
Um,
and I think old sayings get to be
old sayings because they're profound.
Like you're not going to get
hit if you're not swinging well.
Um,
if you're depressed and
so you think slower,
less actively,
you behave less actively,
your chance of getting rewarded goes down,
right?
You don't get out there and you
don't mix it up socially as much.
You don't apply for jobs as much.
You're not as productive
on your job as much,
so you're less likely to get strokes.
You're less likely to get rewarded.
Well,
maybe you go take a pill and it lifts
your mood up so you get more active.
And so now you can start
getting pats on the back.
You start getting people
to engage with you more,
so that lifts your mood and
is that takes care of it.
So you took the medication short term,
you're lifted back up and you're okay.
Short term it can be an alternative.
But I've seen people on everything from
opioids to mood elevators for years and
that's where you lose me.
I just don't get it.
Yeah.
Um,
I know people that had been on things
since they were five years old.
Yeah.
And they're in their forties.
And then you have wastebasket diagnosis
like add and ADHD where you know what
used to be a spoiled
brat is now add or Adhd.
So they start prescribing um,
these Ritalin neo cortical
stimulants like Ritalin.
And if you give a kid that does
not need a neocortical stimulant,
a stimulant,
you're really going to throw him
off the charts now cause you're,
you've got an normally active brain
that you're now making hyperactive.
So you're creating a problem that
didn't exist before you gave him the
medication because you didn't
do the proper diagnosis.
Yeah,
I had my old neighbor had
a situation like that.
They had a kid and the kid was just had
a lot of energy and they weren't paying
attention to them and so
they started medicating them.
It's insanely common.
Yeah.
And you cannot chemically babysit your
children and who knows where these kids
are going to be 20,
30 years from now.
I mean,
we're just looking at this rash of
people being treated for these ailments,
air quotes and then when we're not seeing
how this all turns out in the long run
and how much damage we're
doing to these people.
No.
In fairness,
on the other end of the continuum,
I have seen some people
that are clearly psychotic.
Uh,
schizophrenia,
delusional,
that without medication are
absolutely impossible to manage.
But if you put them on anti psychotics
and so you can lower their delusional
behavior there,
hallucinatory behavior,
so you can now have a
meaningful conversation with
them so they can respond to
talking therapies.
It makes all the difference in the world.
And without those anti-psychotics,
you would be lost without them.
So there are some medications for some
disorders that are absolute miracles that
without them you wouldn't be able to
do the work you need to do to get the
person back where they need to be.
Yeah,
unquestionably.
I mean there's definitely a lot of great
pharmaceutical drugs that helped a lot
of people.
Do you get pushback from a lot of these
positions from the established medical
community?
You know,
sometimes,
but you know,
mostly when you talk to
people about it thoughtfully.
Um,
they agree with,
with what I'm saying.
I mean most people will agree that you
need to be thoughtful about prescribing
medications and that medications
are too readily administered.
I mean that's certainly what we've
seen in the opioid epidemic right now.
Um,
opioids are so readily prescribed
right now that there are Neff opioid
prescriptions for every man,
woman and child in America
to have their own bottle.
And if you renew that
prescription one time,
one time,
if you are taking those
opioids at the seven day mark,
your chance of being addicted
at one year is one in 12.
And if you renew it at,
if you're still taking them at 30 days,
your likelihood of being
addicted is one in three.
Wow.
And these things are getting written
with way too high appeal count.
And it's,
and so the addictions,
uh,
we're,
we're seeing a whole different kind of
addiction now coming out of the suburbs
and they take them for a while and they're
very expensive and actually take him
for a while.
Heroin's cheaper.
So they dumped the opioids
and start taking heroin.
So you're saying soccer mom,
heroin addicts that you weren't saying
10 years ago because they get started on
prescription opioids and
in the can't afford them.
Or finally the doctor cuts them off,
but they're addicted and so they start
taking heroin because it's cheaper.
Now this is obviously a
very disturbing pattern,
but where do you see us going?
Like when you look at the future and mean?
It looks bleak in that regard.
I mean,
I've known several people that
have had real problems with pills.
Yeah.
The problem that,
that I think people have is they think,
because a doctor gave me this because
it's on a prescription pad that this is
safe,
that your body doesn't know whether you
got that in a back alley or you got it
from a doctor.
It still has the same addictive quality.
And I think it is at an epidemic level.
And I've testified before Congress about
this and I think there were several
levels of accountability
at the manufacturing level
and at the prescription
level and at the educational level.
So people understand,
uh,
I think everybody has to take part of it
and I'm doing everything I can to raise
the awareness about it as well.
When you testified before Congress,
what was the reaction?
Uh,
they're very much aware that
this has become a serious,
serious problem because the cost as,
as you see the last labor in the
workforce is in the billions of dollars.
You,
you see the,
the,
uh,
demands on the healthcare system that
this is creating a young mothers with,
with children and babies born
addicted to these opioids.
I mean the numbers are just
going through the roof.
So,
I mean it's putting a strain financially
on healthcare system that it just can't
stand.
So you start costing money and it
starts getting politicians' attention.
So they start saying,
okay,
now we gotta start doing something.
So they,
they get it.
They get that there's a problem.
What could they do though once it
seems like once that genie's out of the
bottle?
Well clearly you've got to
start educating people and
the manufacturers have to be required to
start labeling this much more clearly.
Physicians have to be much more um,
conservative in prescribing.
Um,
you know,
I just had to shoulder surgery and um,
I took like one,
one opioid,
one pill they gave me in the hospital and
after that you can manage it with like
Tylenol or something.
Cause the surgeons now are so good with
the arthroscopic surgeries and stuff,
it's so much less of
an insult to the body.
Uh,
that was ice and Tylenol and stuff.
You can manage it if you just
kind of focus on it a little bit.
And then I might say,
and if,
if you've had surgery and
you're having organic pain,
for God's sakes,
get ahead of the pain and stay ahead.
But when you,
as soon as you can get off of it,
get off of it and
understand what's happening.
Yeah.
There's no sense of being like macho.
We don't need a leather strap between
your cheese and go have some surgery.
I mean,
shit,
if it hurts,
take the pill and get past it,
but realize the minute you
can get away from that,
you need to get away from it.
But you know,
they don't need to give
you a 30 day supply.
Right.
They need to give you three or four
days and then you've got to go see your
doctor again.
If it's still a problem,
discuss it.
I mean,
that's what the,
that's what I think needs to happen to
just be a lot more conservative about
what you're giving
is a promise.
These pharmaceutical
companies make so much money,
they don't want to,
they don't want to back off that they
got private jets and yachts to pay for.
Yeah,
they're starting to shut down.
Some of these,
they had some of these pill clinics in
pain clinics in Florida where you could
go in without an x ray without an MRI
and just say you had back pain and there
was a doctor there that would give you
a 90 count prescription on the spot.
No questions asked 90 [inaudible] and
you're out the door and you go down the
street to the next one.
Yeah.
Cause there was no database,
no database.
And that doctor might be a foreign
doctor that flew in from off shore road.
All the prescriptions during the day
flew off again at night and now they're
shutting that stuff down so
that the hammer's coming down.
Well one can only hope.
Um,
when you've been doing your show,
as long as you've been
doing it and I'm sure you,
you've made a ton of loot,
what,
what makes you want to do a podcast?
Why doing that?
Well my interest has been,
you were saying there were a lot of
people getting their information on the
Internet.
Hm.
By getting clips of the
show and that sort of thing.
And it's clear to me that is
the population is changing.
You know,
I'm an old guy,
but younger people are getting
their information in different ways,
you know,
are going to the Internet and the
menu has got to be readily available and
you can reach a lot of people that way
that you wouldn't reach the other way.
There's a whole population that's not
going to watch broadcast television during
the day.
And there's a whole population that's
watching broadcast television and today
that maybe isn't on in,
in the digital space.
And if I can get a crossover between the
two and you can get a bigger audience
to spread your message,
then you know,
that's what you're doing up.
My goal is to spread the message and
get what I think's important to say out
there.
So I mean,
I'll shout it from the
rooftops if that's what I can,
if I think that's effective,
I want to do anything that's scalable
to get the message out there.
And,
and to me,
uh,
I'm doing,
I'm doing some different things in
the podcast and I'm doing on the show,
on the show.
I've got a fact pattern in front of me.
I've got a story,
I got a family,
got an individual that's got a specific
fact pair and I'm dealing with that fact
pattern in the podcast.
I'm not solving a problem.
I don't have somebody there that
has a problem for me to solve.
I'm just talking to people that I find
interesting and I'm able to talk to them
about whatever I want to talk to him about
and discuss things like you and I are
talking about right now.
I think this is,
I think what we've been talking about
is an important discussion and I welcome
the opportunity to have that discussion
and I don't have time to do that when
I'm talking about somebody
who's sitting there saying,
you know,
I think my kid is on the precipice of
overdosing or is really in trouble and
then I got to focus on that.
I don't have time to pontificate about
such things as the opioid epidemic or the
philosophy of pills versus
therapy and things of that nature.
Cause I have to give all my attention
to the story in front of me in a podcast
environment like we're doing now.
I can't talk about things that
I think people need to hear.
I think it's,
if they don't,
they don't have to listen.
But if they,
if they're interested,
it's there.
So I like it being more free form and
me being able to talk about things.
Um,
I've been talking about what
makes people a champion.
Like I talked to Tony Romo
right after the Superbowl about,
you know,
he came from eastern Illinois University.
It's like got what,
nine students or something and he's a
little bit of university and he turns out
to be quarterback of
America's team for 14 years,
set all kinds of records and then goes
to the booth and becomes a number one
color analyst and
television mean champion,
champion champion.
Why you,
what is it that,
what do you attribute that to?
I like asking those questions
and hearing people talk.
What do you say to
young people about that?
What made you a champion?
Are you going to let your kids play
football with all the CTE and stuff?
What,
what do you say I'm at?
I like having those kind of conversation.
Did the same thing with Shaq and
Charles Barkley and different people.
What did he say about
what makes you a champion,
you know,
for him?
Um,
he said that he has this,
um,
he says he didn't,
he wasn't the kind of
swagger sort of person that,
you know,
came in cocky like he was going
to own the field and own the game.
But inside he said he had this
absolute drive that if he didn't win,
he couldn't live with it is like if
somebody thought like he played the game,
somebody beat them,
beat him.
That just the idea that that person
went home thinking that they were better
than him,
that they could beat him,
that he just couldn't eat sleep.
Think until he got back and owned
it again and got back to it.
He said he just is this drive to win.
And so he would mean,
he said he would be out at one o'clock
in the morning and the dome throwing a
pass,
that that route got intercepted.
He got jumped on that route and he be
trying to figure out why on Thursday in
practice,
he saw what he needed to see,
why didn't he see it on Sunday?
And he would analyze and analyze and
analyze until he could get there,
until he could do it,
until he could win it.
He just had this drive to win
that super unhealthy obsession.
They all share that
Michael Jordan had that.
I mean,
we've talked about that
several times on the podcast.
So many people that are extreme winners,
they're psychotic and their
obsession with winning.
Yeah.
That's all they wanna do.
And if they lose the date day,
it's almost in software,
but they almost can't deal with it.
Yeah.
And I,
I don't know if that's
necessarily a bad thing,
but the difference between winners
and losers as winners do things,
losers do not want to do.
They,
they will get up in the
middle of the night,
they will do this,
they will do that.
They feel it more.
They just do things
losers don't want to do.
They pay a price.
Losers just don't want to pay.
And Luther say it's just not worth it.
And every winter has been loser.
Oh well that's what made him a winner.
If all you ever,
if it's a,
if you go through life as
in a success only journey,
God,
how boring would that be me?
You think it would be great,
but it's like eating ice cream every meal
about the fourth meal you're going to
be thinking,
God,
let's kill something and eat it.
Well it's like who are you
talking about about depression,
about that bad feelings will motivate
you to change if you're in a bad feeling,
if you're,
if you're in a bad state in your life,
that pain is an amazing motivator.
And even though it feels
terrible at the time,
it can propel you to a new and better
life because you don't ever want to
experience that again and make
you grow and be a better person.
Yeah.
And you got to decide
what's your currency.
I mean,
cause you say,
you know,
you've done your show a long time
and probably don't need the money,
but there are different kinds of currency,
right?
I mean you don't always work
for one kind of currency.
I mean every year when we wrap our season,
I kind of take a month and
let everybody go and rat,
you know,
just kind of unwind and relax and kick
back and do whatever they want to do.
And then we start meeting and focusing on,
okay,
how can we reinvent
ourselves for next season?
How can we tell our stories better?
How can we broaden our horizons,
do things different so that we raise
our game because we're kind of competing
with ourselves.
There's,
you know,
we're kind of in a category
by ourselves within the,
when it does what we do.
And we've been number one for a long
time because I got a really hardworking
team,
but we're in a s nobody
else tries to do what we do.
So we're kind of competing with ourselves.
And so we're,
we work real hard to figure out
how can we have a bigger impact?
How can we tell this more effectively?
What techniques can we come up with
that make this even more powerful,
more impactful than what it is?
And that's what,
you know,
that's what really gets me moving.
Well,
it's very telling.
It's,
I mean,
that's why I would imagine you move
towards doing a podcast where it's less
restrictive and more open ended and
you can kind of do whatever you want.
And,
but it's,
that's pretty cool that at all these
years of doing that and giving out advice,
he's still find this,
this passion to,
to make it better and to do
it from a different angle.
Yeah.
And you know,
I'm as excited about,
we're just about to wrap,
you know,
our 17th season
and uh,
that's a lot.
How many episodes you've
done coming up on 3000.
Um,
and I did Oprah for five years before.
Cool.
And uh,
so that's,
that's 22 years and then,
and then I just renewed for five years,
moved out to 20,
23 before you sign that,
like,
what am I,
well,
let's go fishing.
You know,
Robin and I thought about it,
but,
well,
what am I going to do?
I mean,
I don't,
I don't want to see you enjoy it.
Obviously I do.
Yeah,
I enjoy it.
He could tell and I've always told
my team the thing that we don't want,
I don't want to get bored.
And if it gets formulaic for me,
it'll be formulaic for the viewer.
And I don't want that to happen.
And you know,
we do a lot of news stories and stuff
and that keeps it fresh because you don't
know what's going to break
in the news tomorrow.
And so we do most of the really big
news stories and we don't break the news
stories.
We go behind the headline,
talk about here's what really happened.
As Paul Harvey said,
here's the rest of the story is
what you read in the headline.
Now here's,
here's the rest of the story.
And I really liked doing that.
I really like getting into that.
Well,
and when you're doing
this on your podcast,
well I'm,
one of the beautiful
things about that is that,
you know,
you can explore these ideas
without commercial breaks.
You don't have to have anybody
telling you what to do.
You could just,
whatever's interesting to you.
Is that how you pick the subjects and
the people that you're talking to?
Yeah.
Like this week I,
I had on Pam Meyers
who wrote lie spotting,
I spend a lot of motherfuckers,
is that a book on liars by spotting?
Yeah.
And I spent a lot of my
career on deception detection
because I spent a lot of
time in the litigation arena,
uh,
on interrogation technique.
Cause that's how you met over,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
That was when she was doing that.
Uh,
the,
the beef industry was sooner.
Yeah.
The mad cow case in Amarillo,
Eh,
yeah.
She got sued for a couple
of billion dollars and um,
uh,
represented her in that case.
And that's,
that's how we met.
And so,
I mean,
I had Pam on and we've both worked
a lot in deception detection and
interrogation techniques and stuff.
And so just,
and it came right at a time when,
you know Jesse Smollett
is in the news about it.
Is he telling the truth?
Was he not telling the truth?
And in here we have this conversation.
What did you think immediately
when you heard that story?
Uh,
I was very suspicious
when I heard this story.
Jamie and I,
we shut that once the cameras are off,
we're leg these off.
Fuck that guy.
That he's real,
that nobody does this.
It was just too much like a movie.
Yeah.
It was a bad movie.
It's nine below zero and two people are
lying and white just in hopes that he
might come by
who I am.
Yeah.
I mean,
uh,
so strange.
Yeah,
it,
it was suspicious and you know,
he's entitled to due process
and he's going to get it.
Yeah.
He's going to get it.
And now he's saying,
yes,
I'm a untreated drug problem.
So he's trying to carve out some
path to explain his bizarre behavior.
But
there are very,
there are very specific
lie behaviors that people
can't really control.
Like what kind of stuff?
Well,
for example,
when,
when people are really desperately trying
to convince you they're telling the
truth,
they'll do a lot of times what
are called convincing statements.
Um,
rather than just telling you
what they did or didn't do,
they'll do convincing statements.
Like,
you know me,
ah,
like somebody saying,
who's who?
Somebody stole the petty
cash in the office.
You know,
me,
I give more money.
I donate more money
than was stolen yearly.
You guys know me.
I mean,
I was employee of the week,
you know,
there this convincing
you that is a nice guy.
And then they'll say,
when someone does,
if they're wrongly accused and know when
someone gives with the wrongly accused
you of the wrongly accused,
they'll look you straight up in the
eye and tell you I didn't do it.
And if you ask them,
what do you think should
happen to somebody that did,
an innocent person will say,
I think they should be found.
I think it should be held fully
accountable to the extent of the law.
Somebody that's guilty will say,
well,
you know,
I don't know.
I mean,
people make mistakes.
Yeah.
You know,
you got to give a guy a second chance.
Do you worry that in coaching that you're
essentially coaching liars by telling
people this kind of stuff and
someone who does steal the money,
you know,
would be able to kind of like,
Hey,
uh,
it's not for amateurs.
And,
uh,
and um,
when you,
there were some things that you
can tell people to watch for,
but one of the things you do if there's
somebody that you suspect is you
increase their cognitive load during
the interrogation and there's no way you
can prepare for that.
Oh,
how'd you do that?
Well,
um,
you plan a mind virus,
for example,
a mind virus.
Oh yeah.
This is a Perry Mason type shit.
Yeah.
Like when he did,
like,
if,
let's pretend some money's missing,
if I said to you,
um,
is there any reason somebody would have
told me that they saw you near a cashbox
about the time it went missing?
Dumped,
dumped down.
Okay.
Now people talk at 125 words a minute.
They think at 12 to 1400 words a minute.
Now,
if it takes you five,
five seconds to tell me no,
you took the money.
Because if you weren't from his right now,
if you didn't take it,
you know you didn't take it.
You don't need to run scenarios through
your head to think who could have seen
me been.
I mean it was it.
I didn't see anybody.
Nobody could have seen me what did it.
But if you didn't do it,
it doesn't take you one
millisecond to say absolutely not.
Have you ever been wrong before?
And when you see someone
on television and go,
I think that guy's guilty and
they're innocent or vice verse.
Oh sure.
Because if,
if you really want to know for sure
if somebody is guilty or innocent,
you need to invest a lot of time.
You need to get a baseline of
what they normally look like,
talk like,
feel like,
um,
and NBA.
And then knowing that baseline,
you then need to compare
how they're behaving on TV.
So just walking by the
screen and seeing it,
um,
you might see things that would ordinarily
be lie behaviors that could just be
part of their personality.
So if you're going to
really make a judgment,
uh,
you,
you got to put a lot of
time in and figure it out.
And what you should do before you decide
you're going to be a human lie detector
is do your homework and y'all tried to
figure it out objectively before you
figure it out behaviorally.
I mean,
you ought of do your investigation,
find out if somebody took
the money and you know,
find out where they were and you know,
look for fingerprints
and do this and do that.
I mean,
you ought to really objectively figure
it out before you rely on these things.
And so unless you get a baseline and get
one on one with them and spend a lot of
time,
then you can't be,
you can't be really certain that you know,
whether they're telling the
truth or whether or not it's,
it would be fun if it was that easy and
that some people are pretty obvious.
Yeah.
I heard a cop once say that when people
are guilty they tend to plead and cry
and then when they're not guilty they
tend to get angry when they're accused.
People that are wrongly
accused are generally,
I write from the beginning till the end.
I mean the,
every case is different,
but if you're wrongly accused that
person is going to be pissed off from the
minute you accused him till
the end because it's like,
um,
their self.
Raj is like,
I,
I didn't do this and you're
saying I did and screw you.
And they don't take a step back.
And when you,
you see people,
they knew these convincing statements
and they're pleading for you to believe
them.
And then an anytime somebody
says now in all honesty,
usually the next thing
out of their mass ally,
like I said to you now,
now Joe,
honestly,
as opposed to everything
else you've been telling me,
why are we we bracketing
this one out is honest.
Or if they invoke the Deity,
oh,
I swear to God,
God as my witness.
And you know,
I don't know whether I have not done
what I said you need to do with Jesse
Smollett.
But I do know when he
went to the set at Fox,
uh,
he said,
you all know me.
I swear,
God,
I didn't do this.
And I mean,
there were like three or four of those
kinds of statements in like two or three
sentences there.
Well,
my favorite ones,
he's on stage.
He called himself the gay Tupac.
That's enough for me.
That's a little narcissistic.
It's a strange thing though.
Like there was another one today,
a guy a lit his house on fire
and think a in Chicago and uh,
said,
uh,
he's a gay fella,
said it was a hate crime
and they caught him.
So a lot of that going on,
you know,
a lot of fake crime.
Very strange.
The,
the,
and then sometimes people accuse people
of something and someone will say,
why would,
why would someone make something out?
Why would someone turned
themselves into a victim?
What there think there's a lot
of clout and being a victim,
especially today,
there's a lot of,
you get a lot of attention,
a lot of love.
I think there's a lot of false accusations
and false attacks and it's a lot of
real ones.
But man,
when the false ones calm,
but it just does a giant
disservice to everybody.
Well,
there's a fair amount of research
as to why people do these hoaxes and
particularly hate crime hoaxes
and one of the primary motivation,
of course,
it's sympathy and attention and all that,
but one of the interesting reasons
that I've read in research is that they
really feel like it's emblematic of
how the system treats them overall.
This is just a dramatic example of it
and they feel like I'm treated this way
anyhow.
Ah,
so they'd just,
I'm discriminated against,
I suffer by us,
I'm put down.
This is just a focused example of that.
So I'm really not lying.
I'm just role playing
how I'm overall treated.
Oh Wow.
So they justified in their mind of their
disc going to bring all this treatment
into one example to bring it into focus.
And so while it's a phony deal,
it really is truthful representation
of what their life is really likely
justified in that way.
Oh,
how weird.
That's,
yeah,
that's a deep psychological shit.
Yeah.
That's,
uh,
that's stretching.
That's a weird one.
We liked
you ride it out like that.
Put it in your mind that way.
Yeah.
Wow.
It's,
it's strange too because
it gives people this,
um,
this,
this giant public show to watch now.
Yeah.
I hate that family.
What a talented young man.
I mean,
is he,
he's,
I've the Times that I've seen,
I don't want to show a lot,
but the times I've seen him on there
singing and assuming it is his voice and
he's singing,
uh,
extremely talented young man,
I find a lot of talented
people are fucking crazy.
Well,
you know,
somebody said that somebody,
the really talented singers and actors
were the weird kids from high school that
were in drama and all that stuff.
Oh,
for sure.
For sure.
No.
Um,
various levels of crazy.
Obviously not all deceptive,
but you know,
some of the most brilliant actors are
just completely out of their mind.
And that's one of the reasons why they're
so good at acting because they can
look a,
my frame wet and my friend Wayne
Fetterman had a a bit they did about it on
stage and he's like,
guess what?
It's not fucking normal
to be able to just cry.
He goes,
you could just cry and pretend
something's wrong and cries.
I,
that's crazy.
These are crazy people.
Yeah.
And you really can't
go to a certain place.
You've,
you don't have a little of that in you.
My Dad used to always say when
he's working with patients,
you'd would say something about that.
Oh boy,
I can't stand about me.
Cause you say you can't see it in them
if you don't have a little evidence in
you.
I think there's some truth,
there's 100% truth and that,
that is a thing that tries me
the craziest about weak people.
I'm so terrified of seeing weakness and,
and,
and just,
just,
just being pathetic.
I'm so terrified to seeing that in myself.
I see it in other people and it just,
it smells,
I smelled like a drug sniffing dog.
Oh,
there it is.
Yeah.
You smell desperation.
Yes.
What makes you do this?
Why are you doing a podcast?
I have always been a blabber mouth.
I can never shut the fuck up.
I love talk and,
and uh,
I've always been fascinated by human
beings and their lives and just talking to
people and finding out like the guy
before was this guy yo on Grillo,
who's a,
a a narcotics,
a journalist.
He's a narco journalists in Mexico.
I mean,
I couldn't wait to talk to that guy.
just what a life.
And He's been living
in Mexico for 18 years.
He's from England.
I still alive.
So that's something right there.
Yeah.
And He,
you know,
he's telling me about friends that
have been killed and you know,
he's been in some sticky
situations a few times and,
you know,
um,
I'm just fascinated by pit by
people and what they liked to do.
You know,
I'm fascinated by athletes
and fascinated by physicists.
I,
uh,
I've just always been very,
very curious and um,
I've always recognized that everyone
thinks about things differently.
And then I could take a little
bit of something from everybody,
whether it's from a book or it's from
having a conversation with someone,
I can gain a little bit of,
a little bit of experience,
a little bit of knowledge,
a little bit of insight.
Yeah.
You're naturally very curious because
I listened to you interviews and you're
naturally very curious.
You don't struggle for the next
question because you really want to know
something that makes it much easier.
Does very lucky that I found this very,
just stumbled into doing
this kind of Shannon,
why wasn't this way in the
beginning and the big beginning,
it was just horse
shitting with friends and,
and slowly but surely as the pot,
the podcast became popular.
I was like,
I wonder if that guy would talk to me and
then I would get people on and then it
became more these long form
interesting conversations.
Yeah.
If you're curious about
human functioning at all,
human nature at all,
there's an endless menu of
things you can talk about.
And I don't care who it is.
You could,
you could pull somebody out of a car
on the street and if you're curious,
you can talk to him because everybody
has a different take in life.
Everybody has a different walk.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And what you're talking about,
you're interviewing all these athletes,
you know,
um,
I think people tend to write off athletic
pursuits as being entirely physical
and they are not,
I mean I think this is an easy way for
people to look at it that don't engage or
they've never really thought about playing
anything at a very high level that it
requires some intense thinking.
It might not require mathematics
or a large vocabulary,
but understanding what's required,
understanding when and how to execute,
understanding how to keep your
shit together under pressure.
Those are all intensely intellectual
aspects of any really high end athletic
pursuit.
And there's a different breed of cat that
he wants the ball with the buzzer and it,
it's not just a show boat.
There's a different breed of cat
once that ball at that point,
and it's not always who you think,
but it takes a special kind of
person that wants that pressure,
that knows they can handle
it better than anybody else.
Yeah.
You know,
and it's a lot of times it's people
that are entirely confident that they've
done the work.
You know there's a haunting thing that
happens with athletes where you're not
sure if you did enough.
And in fighters it's a very dangerous
inclination because it leads you to
overtrain and you have to be very careful
about that because with a fighter you
only can learn so much
during your training camp.
Like say once you get into training camp,
you got eight weeks
depending on who you are.
Some guys like to do a little longer,
but the average is maybe
eight 12 weeks is a long camp.
You already have to know how to
fight by the time you get to camp.
So what you're really doing is just kind
of working on specific movements where
you're dealing with one kind of fighter
and then getting your body in shape,
getting your body condition
to getting your mind ready,
preparing everything,
cutting your body weight down,
getting so you can weigh in
and have a a good amount of,
um,
just,
it's just,
you gotta have enough vitality,
can't drain yourself.
So this is this complicated dance that
goes on and that haunting thing of did I
do enough?
It can cause fighters to screw
themselves over by overtraining.
Yeah.
So you have to have enough confidence to
know that you've done enough as well as
enough.
You have to know you've done enough.
But no,
you haven't done too much.
This is really strange dance,
you know,
and this,
uh,
this,
this weekend is a giant UFC big
UFC two big title fights between,
for the very best fighters in the world.
And um,
I mean that is one of the interesting
aspects of the fight game to me is one,
watching these guys stare each other down
at the way in where they get a look at
each other.
And they know 24 hours from now they're
going to war and just see like is there
a just us mellowed out?
Is there anything,
is there anything in there?
You know,
and just knowing that this is probably
one of the most difficult things in all
of athletics and that
these guys are going to,
uh,
they're,
they're going to apply their trade and
one of the most complicated things,
it's a battle of physical,
mental,
of,
of mindset,
of we'll,
of conditioning and discipline.
And then it's also,
there's a lot of random shit that happens.
Do you think if I can change at
William when people are looking at it?
Yes.
It can change.
It can shift right then.
It can't change forever by like,
you could look at John Jones sideways,
upside down.
You could stick your toe in.
Ain't gonna Affect Shit.
There's some guys that are just locked
down and bulletproof Jon Jones to pull it
proof.
There's certain guys that
had just bulletproof.
They just look at you and like,
they know what to do.
There's a reason why he's undefeated,
you know?
He's just,
he knows how to do it,
but then there's other guys that
like that may be like fucking,
maybe it's 80 20 maybe,
and then the,
the stare down your look at the
guy and you're looking at him like,
God damn and I'm fighting Yoel Romero.
How the fuck did this happen?
And then you see him drop down
to 75 maybe 73% confidence,
72 70 shit.
They look at his traps.
He's got a neck that starts at the
top of his head and you're like,
oh fuck.
You know,
there's certain guys,
they're just,
they're intimidating at weigh ins too.
Yeah,
yeah.
It can change a little bit,
but not for everybody.
There's certain guys that just,
it doesn't matter.
You can't get in there.
There's certain champions
like real champions,
like mighty mouse,
Johnson.
There's a bunch of guys like
that that are just champions.
You look at them,
it doesn't matter.
They've,
they know what they're doing.
They've done the work that
the best in the business.
Like you can mean mug
them and get aggressive.
They might smile at you.
They might,
this is cute.
Tried to make me nervous.
Hilarious.
See You tomorrow.
Yeah.
So is that because they know who they
are and it doesn't matter who this is or
is it that they just don't,
they don't believe in this guy.
It's,
they know who they are,
I think.
And they have reached a
level of confidence when you
get to a certain level of
success.
Like you know,
John Jones has one loss on his record and
it's by disqualification to fight that
he was destroying the guy and
he was hitting the guy with,
it's a really dumb rule,
but when you throw elbows,
you're not allowed to
throw a 12 to six elbow,
meaning coming straight down.
The only reason that exists is because
when mixed martial arts was first being,
uh,
was first being sanctioned
by athletic commissions,
the,
the people that were in the athletic
commission had some nervous fears of a,
they had seen like those
late night TV shows,
her karate guys are breaking bricks,
the elbow driving straight down.
They thought they could kill
somebody if they did that.
So let's not have,
we'll,
we'll eliminate that strike.
It's a dumb move.
And Jon Jones hit this guy with a
couple 12 to six elbows and he was
disqualified in a fight.
He was just just destroying the guy.
So for a guy like that who has this
staggering resume of achievement,
he's widely considered to be the greatest
light heavyweight champion of all
time.
If not,
he's definitely in the running of the
greatest fighter ever of all time.
For a guy like that,
he's not,
he's,
he's confident to the point of,
you know,
he's,
he's not trying to just beat this guy,
although he's going to beat this guy.
He's trying to go down in history as
one of the greatest of all time or the
greatest of all time.
So for a guy like that,
it doesn't matter what you do,
he's out.
He's a Michael Jordan type character.
You know,
there's a few of those guys out there.
There's these Lebron James is these,
um,
Larry Bird's,
they're there.
They exist in all sports.
They have this mindset,
a champion mindset.
Does he find angry or
does he fight business?
Like business?
Like he's very business like,
yeah,
he's very business.
Like he just knows what he's doing.
The best guys fight business.
Like there's some guys that fight with
emotion and they're still really good but
like fade or Amelia Akos
is famous Russian guy.
He would,
he would have a look on his face that he
was cashing a check and he was smashing
a guy's eye orbit in,
I mean,
he was just,
uh,
you know,
he was the highest level of that,
like that robotic businesslike
approach to fighting.
And then after he knocked you
unconscious to help you get back up.
Yeah,
it was over.
Once he shut her off,
There was no,
no signs.
He thought emotions were weak.
Like showing emotions in a fight,
showing anger,
all that was weak.
Yeah.
I think there's a huge
psychological component to it.
I mean,
I,
I agree completely.
Giant,
gigantic.
I think you've,
you,
I think if you go in with doubt,
man,
I just think that's terrible.
Terrible.
I think he's here because now you're
fighting yourself and them to,
you remember the Mike Tyson
fights when he was in his prime?
Yeah,
I remember the look in those guys face.
Oh yeah.
And they're staring across
the ring and I'm like,
oh Jesus,
what did I sign up for?
There's nothing to lose.
I don't know what the money was here,
but it wasn't worth,
it just seemed like a good idea at the
time as life changing life defining
moment when you,
when you were staring across the ring
at Iron Mike and it was like 1989 he was
at top of the world.
Yeah.
And,
and he,
and you knew he was going
to come over there and,
and it's you mail ever been here before?
Guns blazing.
Yeah.
And he did.
Meanwhile you meet him now he's like
the nicest guy on the planet earth.
Couldn't be sweeter guy.
Yeah.
I taught committed.
He's got a daughter that's apparently
a pretty good tennis player and he's
really behind her now and focused on that.
That was him back then because when he
came out of jail and he's fighting Peter
McNeely,
he's just letting them
know it's common baby.
Terrifying man.
But you know,
he was,
he was never as formidable after
jail as he was before he went in now.
Well,
there's a ton of factors.
His training was never the same.
Um,
you know,
he didn't,
he lost that connection with custom motto.
You know,
he had custom motto with training
them when he was at his very best.
And then Kevin Rooney who worked with
customer and Mike trained him after that,
and then they eventually parted ways.
And,
uh,
that was before the buster Douglas fight.
I remember he had guys in his corner.
It didn't even have an end swell.
I mean,
his eye was swelling up and they
didn't even have ice to put on it.
Yeah,
yeah.
There was a lot of factors.
Um,
but also,
you know,
when I talked to Mike,
uh,
on the podcast,
one of the things was,
and this was just him sort of coming to
grips with the fact that he never really
had a childhood.
His childhood was that from
the time he was 12 years old,
customer Donald took him in,
was hypnotizing him and
teaching him how to fight,
teaching amount of fighting in
hypnotizing him to be a machine is going.
He was literally saying to him,
you don't exist.
The task exists,
the job at hand exists and you're going
to go out there and you're going to get
the job done.
And he was telling this to a 13 year
old that never experienced love.
He just was abandoned and homeless.
And,
and this is the only way he ever got
any sort of positive reinforcement.
And his life is by destroying people.
Yeah,
that's sad.
But you know,
now he seems to really be
connected to his daughter.
I mean,
you,
you see,
you see in here a softness in his voice.
He really is connected to that.
He learned.
No,
I mean,
it's easy to try to look at
someone like who they were,
you know,
20 years ago.
It's,
it's easy to do that.
It's easy to just say,
oh,
he's that guy.
But people evolve and they grow
and he's a great example of that.
He's a very different person.
You know,
he doesn't even work out because
he's worried about his ego.
Like he,
he doesn't hit the bag
or do anything like that.
I said occasionally we'd get on the
treadmill and work out a little bit on a
treadmill just to get
a little exercise in.
But he's worried about feeding his ego
was worried about like looking at himself
in the mirror and bringing
that old monster back again.
Really?
Yeah.
That's what he said.
I think you'd be afraid of not being
able to get back to the level he was.
I don't think he's afraid of that.
I don't think he wants to be that guy.
He says he doesn't like that guy blue,
which is crazy because that guys who
made him rich and famous and everybody
loves him because he was that guy.
But who he is now is a
completely different person.
Just a sweetheart.
A real sweetheart.
Yeah.
He seems like it.
I mean,
you'd never think to talk to him
if you didn't know his history.
You'd never guess that was that guy.
No.
You'd never would.
Yeah.
I think,
uh,
the psychological aspect of fighting is
one of the more intriguing parts of it
to me.
And you know,
for me it's like probably one of the
reasons why I got interested in psyche in
the first place and the way
people think about things and,
and weakness,
like real weakness,
weakness,
weakness can get exposed in
a variety of different ways.
But in competition,
just when you really see it.
Yeah.
I'm one of the,
I have this theory,
you know,
and we see it in sports and I saw it when
I talked to him and he's been a friend
of mine for a long time and I was talking
to him about his psychology is he goes
into a football game and he says he plays
a movie in his mind of the entire game
before he plays it.
Because,
you know,
in a football game you're going to have
11 or 12 possessions during the game and
the football game,
you're gonna get that ball 11 or 12 times.
And he would say,
and I'm going to carry that ball
three or four times per possession,
and he knows which
plays he's going to run.
He would run him through his head,
he would see it,
he would know who was going
to be there to tackle him.
He would run everything through his head.
And he's one of those guys that wants
the ball when the clock's running out.
But I have this theory that situations
do not make heroes situations expose
heroes.
And I saw that in Katrina,
the hurricane that so devastated
that that one neighborhood,
what ward was it?
Is it the ninth ward?
I forget which ward it was.
That got so wiped out,
uh,
when Katrina hit New Orleans and there
was a guy down there that had been really
quiet.
Nobody had ever heard anything out of him.
He was an older guy,
lived in a house,
stayed to himself.
And that night when the
water was at rooftop level,
I mean he swam rooftop
to rooftop and save six,
seven,
eight people got him out of
there and he didn't make it out,
but he got seven or eight people out of
there and you go back and you check his
history and he was a military hero.
He just sat quietly in his home
and when the situation came about,
it revealed who he was.
And I think that's what happens.
I think if you've got a hero,
they just sit there,
sit there and sit there until a
situation reveals who they are.
I don't think it makes him a hero.
I think it reveals that they're heroes
and I think that's what happens to
people.
They,
they are who they are until they get in,
in the opportunity that comes along and
they're going to show you who that is
and they may show you they're a coward
where they may show you that they've got
the focus to hang or they may
show you that they're a hero,
but life circumstances are going to come
along and you're going to show you who
somebody is.
Yeah,
I completely agree.
And I think what's also interesting is
when someone does get revealed to be a
coward,
they can become a hero.
It's very hard.
It's very hard to get past the
memory of you being a coward.
Well,
and I'll tell you why I think that's true.
If
you want to know please.
I mean maybe
going away,
going off on a tangent,
come on.
No,
I think,
I think we learn about ourselves and yo
everybody talks about self esteem and
self worth,
but nobody ever talks about what
it really is or how we get it.
And I think I think about it in terms
of self attribution because you know how
you form opinions of other people.
Like,
if you look at this guy and you,
you maybe you work with this guy and so
you watch him across a couple of years
and maybe this guy shows up to work
every day and he's there 15 minutes early
and he unlocks the place,
gets everything ready,
puts a coffee on,
has his desk ready,
he's all buttoned up.
And Man,
when the bell rings,
he's ready to go.
And you just learned that
this guy's buttoned up,
ready to go.
Dependable never misses.
He's always there.
So you attribute certain traits and
characteristics to him based on your
observations of him and your experience
of him based on that you assign certain
traits and characteristics to him.
But I say that's exactly the same way
we form our own self image and our own
level of self worth.
We watch ourselves go through life
and we watch how we handle certain
circumstances and situations.
And that's why I say overindulgence is
one of the most insidious forms of child
abuse known to parenting.
Uh,
it's not the worst.
It's just insidious because
if you overindulge your
children and do everything
for them,
you never let them observe themselves,
master their environment.
You never let them step back and say,
wow,
I did that.
I built this,
I overcame that,
I handled this,
I did that.
And so we,
that's the same way we make our own
self image and level of self worth.
We watch ourselves
overcome the third grade.
We watch ourselves stand up to a bully,
we watch ourselves handle a test with
the information that intimidated us or we
watch ourselves make it on to the Little
League baseball team and actually get a
hit when we needed to.
Where we watch ourselves get on to the
debate team and actually argue something
successfully,
whether it's academic
or athletic or musical.
We watch ourselves do it
and so we go back and say,
Hey,
I did that.
I attribute to myself the ability,
I can hang,
I can do this.
I can rise to the occasion.
Or we watch ourselves fold like a
pup tent and a windstorm and say,
you know,
I can hang.
I don't have it.
And we make those
attributions to ourselves.
And so we strength from the challenge
for the rest of our lives until like you
said,
it's hard to overcome that and something
pushes you up until you finally observe
yourself overcome something.
And I think that's how we form our level
of self esteem and our identity about
who we are.
And I don't think most
people think about that.
Look back and say,
okay,
how did I,
how did I get to be Joe Rogan?
As I sit in a chair,
you have a self image,
you have a level of confidence,
ego,
strength,
uh,
a level of self worth that's attributable
to things you've watched yourself do
or not do,
achieve,
not achieve,
overcome or whatever throughout your life.
And,
and I think to know yourself,
you have to know what those things are.
I think you're 100% right.
And I think for children participating
in things that are going to test you so
critical,
giving them this opportunity
to realize that the,
the,
there's a line between success and failure
and that you could push through that
line.
You could,
you could become successful at
something and learn watching kids.
I,
that's why I think sports are
so important for children.
I think that's one of the more insidious
things about having these participation
trophies for kids where
that nobody wins the game.
Yay.
Everybody plays.
But nobody wins.
We don't keep score.
Why the fuck you plan?
Yeah.
I mean that just goes down as
an environmental non event.
Yeah.
I mean that contributes nothing to your
definition is just something to do.
It's also psychologically,
it's coddling.
It's very,
it's very damaging for your potential
education that you would get from that
situation.
The bad feeling that you get when someone
scores on you is motivation for you to
be better at defense.
Yeah.
You know,
I think we cheat kids when we do that,
and of course you gotta play everybody.
I get that not everybody
is meant to be an athlete,
so,
okay,
look,
go do something else.
Be Good at what you're good at.
And if you really want to do it well,
you've got a long road.
It's a greased hill.
Start running.
Yeah.
Everything's not for everybody.
So find what you're good at and
watch yourself achieve in that lane.
You know,
that's like,
I,
I can't carry a tune in a bucket.
I can't even,
I can play no instrument.
I can't sing.
I can play a radio of,
it's got a big on off knob.
That's it.
And so I,
I don't try,
I mean,
that's,
I'm just not good at that.
So I go into lanes that I can do
stuff and observe myself in that.
But I think you cheat kids if you
don't let them observe themselves face
adversity and overcome it.
Absolutely.
And it's also an interesting lesson
to learn that life isn't fair.
I mean,
if you're a kid and you're playing
basketball with a 15 year old Lebron James
and you're my height,
you go,
Huh,
yeah,
this ain't gonna work out at all.
Yeah.
You're looking at a towel boy here.
This is not fucking happening.
And you have to be able to
that and appreciate that.
And then conversely,
if you're very physically frail,
you know,
maybe wrestling's not for you either.
You know,
maybe,
maybe you,
uh,
we need to do something about your
body before you engage in any sort of a
combat sport.
You know,
they did an experiment back in,
I think it was the 60s they did
something called teaching machines.
Have you ever seen that?
No.
Short period of time.
But they,
they took students in the class where
they put the steps of learning the
information so close together that
there was never a failure experience.
It would say like the war of 1812 happened
in 1812 then the next thing would say
the war of 1812 happened in blank.
You fill in 1812.
I mean come on,
potted plant could get that.
So they've put it together and they would
teach the information and they would
teach it to criteria where
you mastered the information.
You had it 100% and I said,
wow,
this is great.
Everybody learned it.
So everybody made a hundred,
everybody got the information,
they truly did learn it.
There was no question about it.
They learned the information
and so they did great.
And then they took them
out of that program.
And put them back in
the regular classroom.
And the first time they came to questions,
they didn't know the answer to.
The first time they didn't get a hundred
they came apart like a cheap suit.
They panicked,
they didn't know how to handle adversity,
they didn't know how to handle it when
they didn't have the right answers,
they didn't learn how to not be perfect.
And so they scrapped the whole program
because he said you can't do this because
that's not the way life is.
And if,
I mean it's,
you're not teaching them
how the real world works,
you might as well teach them to go on
red and stop on green and then give them
the keys and put them out in life.
Cause that's not the way it works.
And those kids were absolutely screwed
up when they got into a truly competitive
environment.
It can't be success only.
Yeah,
it doesn't make any sense.
It's not healthy.
It's not good for you.
You don't learn from it.
I mean the whole idea about school is
you're supposed to be setting kids up for
the future.
He's supposed to be teaching them,
not just information,
but teaching them how to learn.
And
Yeah,
and that worries me.
You know,
I've read that story not
long ago when new students,
I think it was at Ucla in law school,
complained and got a professor either
disciplined or fired because he required
them to take a counter argument over
something controversial like Ferguson.
He said,
I want you to,
you know,
I know you that you're
all on this point of view.
Now I want you to prepare an
argument for the other side.
And they all said,
ah,
that's,
that's upsetting to us.
We just can't do it.
And they went to the administration and,
wow,
that's crazy.
Because you may have to do,
as a lawyer,
you may have to represent someone who's
done something you don't agree with.
If that's what you want
to do for a living.
Right.
I mean,
are you kidding me?
They were like needed therapy.
I'm like,
what the hell has happened here?
Oh my God,
that is so crazy.
That's nuts.
That's crazy.
You know?
Um,
yeah.
Well,
there's a,
there's a movement going on
in this country right now,
the social justice movement and a,
it leans in that direction that people
don't want to look at things for how they
are.
They want to look at things
for how they want them
to be.
Yeah.
That just,
I just don't understand.
You cannot
legislate that everything is going to be
equal for everybody because everybody's
not equal.
I'm sorry.
They're not equal.
They may be equal in terms of
their value as a human being,
but they're not equal in mass skills.
They're not equal in how fast they run.
They're not equal in creativity.
They're not equal.
Everybody has their own value,
but that doesn't mean they're marketable.
Skills in an open society and an
open market are going to be the same
now.
It's ridiculous.
I used to have,
I had a joke on one of my special
saw two specials ago about,
uh,
there was a story about a woman
who was guarding the White House.
She was the lone guard at one of the doors
of the White House and some crazy man
broke in and uh,
knocked her to the ground and just
ran through the White House and he was
running around inside the White House for
like three minutes before they finally
some off duty.
Uh,
see a secret service
agent tackled this guy.
I saw like,
what the fuck is going on?
This guy's running
through the White House,
tackle this guy,
and that the joke was that people think
that a woman can do everything a man can
do.
I go,
a woman can do everything a man could do.
Is that true?
And some woman in the crowd
of the comedy store is like,
yes.
I go,
well,
that doesn't make any fucking sense.
Here's why it doesn't make
any sense because a man
can't do everything a man can
do.
I go,
look,
I've met Shaquille O'Neal and
his Dick is where my face is.
And if the White House has
experienced seeing a Shaq attack,
I'm the wrong person to save the world
because he's just going to run right over
me.
I go,
but if my wife and kid where garden,
the White House,
guess what I'm getting in?
Okay.
I love my family,
but if it's between me and get it,
there's no way they're
going to be able to stop me.
I loved them to death,
but I'm a man and they're women and if
there's a woman guard in the White House,
I don't care who she is,
I'll fuck her up.
It's not going to happen.
This is crazy.
But this,
someone had this idea that they would
put a woman in charge of a very physical
job.
You should have a giant man with a
violent temper and he should be armed.
Okay.
Cause this is the guy that's keeping
bad people from the fucking president.
Yeah.
Uh,
I don't know.
I don't understand.
It just seems like you
got to find your own lane.
I mean,
yeah.
You don't want to put me in the NBA.
Yeah.
Physical things in particular.
And then there's also mental things.
Look,
I suck at math.
Okay.
If,
if,
if everyone has a chance to work at cern,
right.
Everyone has a chance to work
at the large Hadron collider,
including people that have
no idea about physics.
We're going to have a real time
making these equations work.
Yeah,
that's what I mean about
finding your own lane.
Yeah.
Cue.
I can't add two and two
and get five every time.
I'm just not good at math,
but I'm good with words.
I can talk.
I can read faster than
I can comprehend well,
but I'm not good with math,
so I got myself into a lane
where I talked for a living.
I read,
I talk,
I,
it's qualitative,
not quantitative.
I can accept that I'm not suited for that.
I mean,
I don't feel bad about
myself because of that.
Once you do something
and you're good at it,
you can accept not being
good at other things.
It's much easier if you find
the thing that you're good at,
whether it's gymnastics
or singing or painting,
whatever the fuck it is.
If you could find a thing
that you're good at,
it will make you,
it'll give you a feeling of self
worth and you won't need to be good at
everything you can accept and you can
enjoy other people being good at things as
well.
Yeah.
You know what I said earlier,
my dad was an alcoholic and I would
compare myself to that kid across,
cause I had a damaged personal truth,
but I found a currency because at that
time in my life I was a pretty decent
athlete for this small
school I was going to.
So that was my currency.
Yeah.
So now it didn't matter what was happening
at home because I got strokes for
being able to jump high
and run fast at school.
So that became my currency.
So now when I compared myself to him,
okay,
maybe my home life wasn't as good as his,
but I could run faster and jump higher.
So that became my currency.
So now I,
okay.
That leveled the playing field for me.
And you all would,
like you said,
find what you're good at at a given
time and do what you're good at.
Yeah.
Find something you love,
find something you're passionate about
and that you could also excel at.
And if you can work it out where it's
your vocation and your avocation,
you love doing it and you get paid for it,
then you're just double blessed and
then you got it right because you enjoy
doing this and it works
out and that's good.
Yeah.
You catch lucky breaks if you the image,
but that's,
boy,
that's lucky.
Yeah,
it is.
And if I just think if you're
in your life and theirs,
you don't have something
that you're passionate about.
I mean,
and I don't mean that in a cliche way.
If there's not something where you wake
up every day and there's nothing in your
life that you're excited to do,
man,
you need to go back to the drawing board.
Yeah.
Because if all you're doing
is just grinding it out,
you get up everyday,
go to a job you don't like,
do task you don't care to do and come
home to a home you don't want to come home
to and wait to get them to
do it again the next day
you're burning daylight.
What the Hell existences that.
I just,
I don't,
I don't understand that,
that find something.
I don't care if it's gardening or
music or art or athletics or something.
Find something you're excited to do.
Expose yourself to different things with
that very purpose of finding something
that you love because
the assumption out there,
there's something out there.
I guarantee you something.
Yeah.
There's something healthy.
It's not illegal.
It's not going to be high risk.
There's something you can do that's not
going to kill you or put you in jail
that you can be excited about.
Yeah.
And I think it's,
uh,
one of the most important things to do
when you're a parent is to try to expose
your kids to as many different things as
possible to find those things for them.
Yeah.
And I,
I got two boys as you know,
and you know,
one of them really well,
and I did that growing up because my dad
never took me hunting a single day in
his life.
He never took me fishing
a single day in his life.
He never took me camping
He never took me to the lake.
He never took me skiing,
boating,
anything.
So I,
I took them to all of those things.
I didn't know.
I had no clue what I was doing,
but I took him Turkey hunting,
duck hunting,
deer hunting,
she's skiing,
snow skiing,
camping.
I did it all.
And to see what they liked,
let them pick.
And boy,
when you don't know what
you're doing as a dad,
that's a bitch.
Yeah.
I mean,
just little things like you,
you go camping and you don't realize
that sit in your 10 up on the side of a
hill,
even if it's like eight or
10 degrees is a bad idea.
Yeah.
Sleep.
You've got to get on flat ground.
I mean,
it looks flat to me,
but I spent the night try not
to roll down to Damn Hill.
It didn't look like it was on a slant,
but it was,
but you figure these
things out as you go along.
But I was glad I gave him those
experiences so they could choose.
And they did.
And they will.
And there's some of it
they liked some of it.
They didn't,
well I don't know both the kids,
but I love J.
Yeah.
Jay loves you.
He really enjoys spending time with
you guys and traveling with you guys.
And Yeah,
we've had a bunch of great trips.
He's an awesome guy.
He really is so much fun.
Yeah.
He,
he knows how to have a good time.
And he says the same thing about you.
He's,
you know how to have a good time.
Yeah.
Well,
listen man,
uh,
tell people how to get
ahold of your podcasts.
Where can they get it?
Well,
it's fill in the blanks and uh,
that's p h I l in the blanks and uh,
yeah,
I guess you get it everywhere.
Podcasts are gotten right yet.
Tones,
all that jazz,
iTunes,
apple,
a stitcher,
all the different places that
you're doing right there.
He handsome faster.
Yeah.
Look at that.
I mean,
how bout that thing up?
Nice.
I'll do clean up pretty good though.
I see.
The good thing about being bald
as you look the same all the time,
right?
Yes,
that's true.
And you save money on shampoo.
You shaved money on shampoo.
And I've been bald since I was like 12
so really my hair fell out really early.
Wow.
I remember playing college football.
I'd take my helmet off and it looked
like I had an animal in there.
Once a pill,
it's going on here.
My team,
I should say what the
hill is in your helmet.
It's my hair shut up.
I don't know why,
but it just fell out.
I guess he got knocked out
or the mustache works too.
Yeah.
Well some a lot of guys
can't rock a mustache.
I'd look a little creepy with one.
Yeah.
Well I tried to keep it where
it doesn't look like total porn.
That's tough.
How do you do that?
You got to embrace your weaknesses.
You know,
I mean,
I remember when I wrote
my first book on Oprah,
she said,
you'll you won't have
any trouble finding it.
It's got these big old ball head
right there on the front of it.
So I figure,
you know,
hell,
make it a trademark.
Right.
For went hard on Ya.
Yeah,
she did in the beginning.
I got no complaints.
Oh,
I hear you.
She treated me pretty right.
Yeah,
it worked out great.
Hey,
thanks for having me on my pleasure.
You got to come do mine.
Absolutely.
Alright,
thanks man.
Dr Phil,
Ladies and Gentlemen.